[Musica]
Mi sentite Sì ok grazie tanto l'azienda
l'ho costituita con un altro grandissimo
pezzo di cuore che qui è rosso e si
chiama Flavia
e capirete l'importanza che ha in questa
storia in questa persona
Intanto io Come imprenditore ma alle
volte ci si aspetta che un imprenditore
parli della propria impresa o delle
proprie imprese in realtà non è così Io
vorrei parlarvi Timidamente della storia
di un uomo
un uomo che allora devo dirvi io non
avevo voglia di fare niente
niente niente
Non sono solo non solo ok
questa questa mia capacità di non far
proprio niente di non impegnarmi niente
ha portato
eravamo diciamo con la scuola Insomma La
Terza Super terza media Scusate in terza
media la professoressa di italiano dice
a mamma Mirella che è qua le dice suo
figlio lo deve mandare a lavorare
la mandi a lavorare Tanto non fare
niente nello studio non è possibile
quella creatura che qui con noi Mamma
mia lo dice no facciamo così lo mandiamo
a fare almeno un professionale per il
commercio quindi si fa tre anni
Mal che vada saper fare di conto giusto
mamma
insomma non solo fa questo ma mamma
Mirella decide di farmi bocciare in
prima in prima superiore mi fa bocciare
perché il tuoso Gadda maturare detto in
dialetto veneto vuol dire che il ragazzo
deve maturare siamo a Venezia me lo
permettete da lì però capita qualcosa di
particolare perché la vita comincia a
cambiare prendo un colore molto diverso
perché prende il come dire il colore
della consapevolezza di sapere che
qualcosa so fare
come dire rivedendo un po' le materie
così via dicendo parte un po'
l'autostima Insomma arrivo di slancio
nella terza superiore Mia mamma dice Dai
che forse si ferma in realtà io vado
perché a quel punto ho maturato l'idea
che con forza volevo far vedere al mondo
cos'è ero capace di fare avevo un po'
deciso ultimamente che avrei spaccato
punto
e quindi ho cominciato oltre si poteva
fermare il terzo anno ho fatto il quarto
il quinto e comincio a vado
all'università Addirittura quindi grande
sorpresa ovazioni via dicendo Insomma
parto comincio a studiare lingue
comincio finiscono questa mi muovo
comincio a viaggiare il mondo e
soprattutto comincio a mettere a terra
questa grande energia che ho per fare
qualcosa di grande nella mia vita
Attenzione però molto focalizzato nel
successo personale nell'avere
un qualcosa
a un certo punto la mia vita conosco una
persona che è da noi per una
riorganizzazione aziendale l'azienda
andava benissimo nel 2010
è lì vi garantisco che
c'è stato un boom nel mio cervello
stesso qualcosa di veramente che mi ha
sconvolto perché
questa persona mi fa una domanda che
rimette insieme
tutto la domanda che poi vi regalo alla
fine non ve la voglio dire Adesso bene
grazie a quella domanda Io capisco che
c'è qualcosa di diverso che in realtà
quello che io ero che volevo volevo
essere in quel momento lì non era
esattamente ciò che ero
non ero non ero ero più destinato voglio
dire a quello che dovevo ottenere avere
che non rispetto quello che io ero
veramente intimamente Mi ero perso avevo
cercato Secondo me la direzione
sbagliata avevo cominciato veramente
adesso un uomo che otteneva forzando
sugli altri rispetto quello che lui
voleva che gli altri prendessero Come
forma e questo non va bene questa per
quanto sia gentile si chiama violenza io
la chiamo violenza e quindi questo modo
questa energia immensa che io comunque
sento di avere a un certo punto è
diventato un male
grazie a quella cosa lì invece a questa
persona Io comincio a ragionare in
maniera diversa e comincio a dire Ma se
la direzione anziché essere fuori
fossero dentro di noi e quindi
decido di fare un passaggio molto
importante ci lavoro molto e decido di
mettere i valori al centro di quello che
io ero attenzione che nel momento in cui
si fa un lavoro nella ricerca i propri
valori è un lavoro profondissimo lavoro
molto difficile da fare c'è veramente di
fronte a se stessi Anche perché poi sia
di fronte a come noi li portiamo in ciò
che siamo in tutto ciò che siamo Questi
sono i miei tre valori principali il
senso di protezione
la libertà e la forza intesa come forza
buona è una forza buona sono
descriverli non sarebbe facile Ok
comunque questa riproduzione è compreso
No cioè uno proteggere che è con me deve
sapere chi chi è il mio nella mia sfera
più vicina è protetto da me come come se
lui si sentisse che ha un fratello un
padre un figlio è protetto Libertà nel
lasciare gli altri liberi di essere ciò
che sono come io voglio essere libero
attenzione e forza quella forza che ti
permette anche di fronte alle difficoltà
di superare tutto di spaccare non so se
vi siete mai sentiti questa cosa no che
avete voglia proprio di andare e fate
bene
a un certo punto però questo comincia a
metterlo in ordine rispetto tutti quelli
che sono gli schemi no della tutti i
lati la nostra vita vediamo un po' la
vita come un raggio di sole no E ogni
raggio di sole è composto di una cosa di
una parte bellissima no che io stavo in
realtà violentando non stavo più
gestendo come ero veramente io ho
scoperto quello che ero io veramente
ultimamente Beh allora Beh non era più
il marito di prima ero marito tanto
stavo bene perché di guadagnavo un po'
anche un po' di autostima in quello che
succede intorno a me era un padre
migliore mi trovavo eh Un amico migliore
mi ritrovavo mi sono ritrovato anche
visto che d'impresa parliamo un
imprenditore migliore i risultati dico
sempre i bilanci si sono depositati si
scaricano Non si guardano ho parlato del
2010-11 e vedete che meraviglia viene
Che tipo di scambio si può creare perché
di scambio si parla qui si cambia si
parla di scambio valoriale e quando io
scambio noi siamo qui perché scambiamo
dei valori no non saremmo qua o siamo
alla ricerca più un messaggio valoriale
giusto Pensate cosa riescono a fare i
valori
la domanda e io qui Mi rivolgo ad ognuno
di voi
ad ognuno di voi dovete darmi tutta la
vostra attenzione perché voglio farvi
questo piccolo Passaggio questo piccolo
regalo
se tu avessi un figlio Se non ce l'hai
devi immaginare come se lo avessi una
cosa veramente importante no
cosa gli trasmetteresti di assolutamente
fondamentale
quella cosa che sai che per lui farà la
differenza e gliela trasmetteresti a
qualsiasi costo
è quel passaggio Veramente io qui scrivo
intimo personale di consegne che fai nei
confronti di una creatura perché sai che
lo userà per essere una persona
meravigliosa nel mondo e lo aiuteranno
momenti di difficoltà
Ci avete pensato
la prima roba che mi è venuta in mente
la prima cosa che mi è venuta in mente
bene
ora riportatele alle sfere che vivete
quello è la magia di quello che noi
siamo il cercare le rotte Troppo spesso
le cerchiamo fuori quando la rotta più
grande più bella quella che ci emoziona
ce l'abbiamo dentro di noi quella grande
forza che ci permette di batterci per
delle battaglie straordinarie non
parlare con vibrazione del voce perché
amiamo quello che abbiamo che stiamo
facendo bene questa è davvero davvero
valore e me stesso sono la cosa più
importante perché quando io sto bene con
me stesso in linea con i miei valori e
allora riesco veramente a esprimermi al
massimo e travolgere gli altri di quello
che io sono perché quella è la vostra
intimità è la vostra identità
È così che nel mio piccolo secondo me si
costruisce la storia la vera storia
quella profonda bella di un uomo o di
una donna
buona vita
[Applauso]
grazie grazie grazie grazie grazie